so jetzt rückwärtsgang einlegen
servus s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute mal ein blog der
gestern abend
dies wird ziemlich schlecht ich war
krank die geschichte dazu könnt ihr euch
erzählen ich habe mir abends nach dem
training bei rewe dann geführt 1 80 m
protein riegel geholt oder tiere gerne
richtig heftige bauchschmerzen bekommen
dann habe ich mal darauf geschaut was
sagt das mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum
august 2015 also schon so circa zwei
monate darüber warum geht ihr wieder
besser machen wollte einfach mein block
und zwar nicht irgendeinen block sondern
da hinten ist mein büro ich würde sagen
ich zeige euch heute einfach mal mein
büro wo ich in berlin den ganzen tag
verbringen und arbeiten weil es echt
cool so richtig coole features ich
nichts mache ich als praktikantin
natürlich denn gefragt ist ein schlüssel
ein bisschen verbogen ist so sieht's aus
dem eingangsbereich hier vorne
hier haben wir natürlich erst mal an der
whisky bar wo ich noch nicht gesehen
habe dass jemand immer benutzt hat das
team besteht glaube ich nur zu
dekorationszwecken mit habanero chips
ganz wichtig und allen möglichen
spirituosen diesen totenkopf schädel
wodka gin wahrscheinlich nochmal wodka
whiskey alles mögliche dann laufen jetzt
mal hier weiter durch das ist jetzt
nicht der bereich in dem ich arbeite
sondern da sitzt so ein bisschen die
geschäftsführung glaube ich hier in
diesem zwischenraum quasi und jetzt
weiter durchziehen hier vorne die
entwickler die die website kunden die
server manager whatever die alles
mögliche design und da hinten ist auch
schon das ende des büros also das ist
quasi
ertappte land das muss er lernen 1234
räume mit diesem zwischenraum das ist
der entwicklung da vorne durchgelaufen
setzt die geschäftsführung wir laufen
jetzt mal weiter zu meinem arbeitsplatz
denn das wahrscheinlich spannendste für
euch da wo ich setze kein thema zeigen
ich weiß nicht ob ich aufgeräumt habe
ehrlich gesagt hier drüben im
meetingraum dann euch sogar schon mal
drin
30 gewohnt so hier sitzen dann so meine
direkten kollegen da ist mein
arbeitsplatz nicht hier sondern legt
sogar auf eine alte schiene von der
tätigkeit im mini up gemacht habe ich
wollte nämlich eigentlich den blog erst
mit der gh vier hier film von marvin ist
auch richtig nimmt sogar in 4k auf dem
video oben dran
die sache ist ich hätte einfach mit
diesem stativ ihr film müsste ich etwas
in der hand halten müssen
geb ich das mache das ist parking schwer
dass sie zusammen locker so 78 kilo tor
weiß man hier über so sieht es aus das
meine arbeitszeit wenig bekommen hier
liegt alles mögliche um hier natürlich
ganz wichtig eine karte von europa die
habe ich auch nur man die kosten des
bloc haben bei der bundeszentrale für
politische bildung
danke für 80 das ist meine tasche hier
drüben ist sogar noch der decke sieht
das aus von dieser kennen kenne ich
keinen von dieser sonic ist das lumix zu
dieser monitor wird einfach nicht wird
diese laptop stand damit auch nicht
wobei eigentlich eigentlich und 1 grad
am rhein
eigentlich könnte ich meinen laptop hier
so drauf packen und dann per hdmi mit
dem bildschirm verbinden das wäre nicht
viel cooler richtig dumm von mir warum
ich das nicht keine ahnung
so sieht das aus dem büro aus der
ausblick da unten bin ich sogar mal
angefragt
mit einer sache die ich euch jetzt
fahrzeuge verkauft ist das hier
nee da ist es nicht das steht hier drin
ist dann wir schauen jetzt mal an ich
habe es bisher noch nicht in einem blog
gezeigt überhaupt nicht dass die
absolute premiere und ich aber noch
nicht gesehen dass irgendein anderer
youtuber in deutschland das hat deswegen
haltet euch fest wir kommentieren den
aufenthaltsraum rein dass da draußen
waren die arbeitsräume leute arbeiten
hier drin ist der aufenthaltsraum jetzt
gebt euch mal dass hier ein elektrisches
lambotte richtig geil damit bin ich und
auf der straße gefahren
gebt euch mal diese reifen hier
vollgummireifen kann man über jeden
belag von wisst ihr was ich zeige euch
jetzt mal den rest von diesem auftrags
raum dann fahren wir einfach mal eine
runde durchs büro mit diesem
elektrischen longboard alter das macht
doch so hier auf jeden tisch stehen
immer alle möglichen snacks da war
mittags schon pizzabrötchen dass es
mittlerweile weg hier in süßigkeiten wie
hinten
der kühlschrank alles wirklich drin afri
cola bla bla bla bla und bier natürlich
auch für den feiern sogar ein tanz und
ganz wichtig wenn man sich zwischen
lieber wissen erdnussflips
alter schwede so hier ist eines der
wichtigsten teil des ganzen büros
nämlich die kaffeemaschine ganz wichtig
da drückt man den knopf an da kommt der
kaffee raus wasserspender schlagt ihn
einfach so kaputt da draußen ist so
aufenthaltsbereich aber das war jemand
von anderen laden deswegen lass mal
lieber mit dem team auf jeden fall kann
man hier draußen auch noch ganz leute
hier draußen noch mal ganz gut spielen
wenn man besten einsparen muss das hier
ist unser kino bereich mit bier pyramide
natürlich ganz wichtig das sind 5 wird
der profis also 5 10 15 20 25 30 35
liter bier
die dann noch um stehen plus noch mal 5
meter im kühlschrank damit kommen wir
auf
40 liter bier die in diesem büro darauf
warten vernichtet zu werden also in
wohlgemerkt nur in festlaune hat den
kühlschrank gesehen haben wir auch
bierflaschen die vorne
die auch noch bierkästen ist schlicht da
oben sind nur auf ein paar dinge also
hier geht es um mal hoch mit einer
treppe warum sind ein paar ablagefächern
der wand und ich glaube in vach 12 seht
ihr fach 12 das müsste das hier sein
da sind die süßigkeiten versteckt das
hat mir die christin verraten wie habt
ihr fest gesehen die blonde verraten
dass da die süßigkeiten versteckt sind
das weiß keiner hilft da nicht weiter
sagen denn sonst kommen alle dessen
gewicht hatten weg die eigentlich hier
sein sollten prinzip ist nämlich so aus
der käufer heute morgen voll mit duplo
und kinderschokolade und jetzt ist er
leer gefressen es gibt nur diese
komischen kekse jahren obst nennen
das geht so nicht büro soweit gezeigt
jetzt gehen wir auf select bestellen
wollte ich zeig euch mal wie das
funktioniert hier ist es das prachtstück
so man schaltet das ding hier an wenn es
gerade im geladen dann hier auf der
fernbedienung drückt man diesen knopf
dann verbindet sich und jetzt müsste es
eigentlich gehen halte ich hab noch nie
stehend auf dem longboard gefilmt und es
bewegt sich wirklich um ihre nicht dass
es gleich am tisch nannte das praktische
ist das ding hat auch im rückwärtsgang
also wenn man den knopf drückt jetzt
zurück
aber hier im aufenthaltsraum des
bisschen engen ich würde sagen wir gehen
noch mal rüber in den arbeitsbereich und
fahren da noch einmal durch
das ist ein kleines wendemanöver machen
übrigens wenn man das also man das ding
zurückzieht bewegt vorne
wenn man hochbrück bremste weil die
bremsen richtig spaß rückwärtsgang
einlegen was drehen ist einfach mal so
und dann fahre ich jetzt die nummer
durchgegangen nein finden nach vorne
so leute das was vom heutigen glaub ich
hast du dich gefallen mal kein gaming
morgen kommt abrechnet wiedergeben was
bislang drei macht's budo